i supported the raiders last night
because i picked the raiders to win and
there's something about even though i
won't gamble big cat there's something
about having a competition with someone
you work with and sims and i have a
competition full season all the picks
and we disagreed last night i had the
raiders he had the chargers that made
that game so much more exciting to me
now i know how you feel when you've got
money on a game i was into it and the
chargers and the raiders had what was
kind of a sluggish game for
long stretches but when it got down to
crunch time when the chargers went ahead
with 402 left it's like can derek carr
and the raiders really pull this off can
they drive down the field and score and
they did 75 yards 10 plays josh jacobs
pops through for the touchdown and then
when daniel carlson missed the extra
point there it was the ball's on the t
the opportunity for philip rivers to do
philip rivers things and get the
chargers in position to win that emerged
and of course they failed to do it and i
saw some of your tweets last night when
you got three time outs
and roughly a minute to play
what the hell are you doing throwing the
ball 30 yards downfield on every snap
it was absolute insanity now the
chargers have played the exact same game
for the last decade straight and that is
close game back and forth phil rivers
with the ball a minute left trying to
score and what they did with those eight
plays they were 0 for 7 and then
including an interception to end the
game three timeouts in your pocket all
you have to do is go 40 yards for a
field goal how do you not a little run
maybe a screen phil rivers now i watched
watching it back because i did say it's
crazy that anthony lynn went you know
lost the game with two timeouts in his
pocket you cannot lose a close game and
have timeouts in your pocket that's not
a uh thing that you can carry over where
he gets five timeouts in the first half
next week so i watched it back a little
bit there were some underneath things
that were philip rivers was trying to
hit he just was terrible he was really
really bad i think anthony lin screwed
up by not giving him maybe like a draw
or a screen because when you have three
timeouts mike and you only have to go 35
yards and you have a minute left on the
clock that's like 10 minutes of football
that is more than enough football if
that happened to aaron rodgers that
happened to tom brady if that happened
russell wilson would you even blink
would that even be a question that they
would be able to get their team into
field goal range russell wilson did it
last week against the bucks i think he
had one timeout in like you know 45
seconds and he got down to field goal
range in 15 seconds it's so easy for a
quarterback to get 40 yards with three
timeouts and a minute left at the end of
the game and this means that to me
i hate to say it but we've seen eli get
benched this year we've seen big ben go
out with an injury but this might be the
end of the 2004 draft class which is an
unbelievable quarterback draft class
because phil rivers looks like he is
at the end of the career right here
because that was really bad 0 for 7 with
an interception at the end of the game
none of them really even close just
hucking and heaving down the field uh he
now mike 12 out of the last 16 games
that phil rivers has played he's had
doubled uh at least two interceptions or
more so i feel like this is more an
indictment on the chargers going forward
and we got to get to the raiders we will
but i have questions about phil rivers
going forward and how many uh years he
has left probably only one maybe
i don't think he has that many not not
with the chargers and we've been talking
about that all week the things the
chargers can do i think cam newton is a
candidate for the chargers next year if
he doesn't stay with the carolina
panthers but i think rivers is done i
could see him with the titans next year
to kind of end his career for a year or
two but but let's let's focus on
the the philosophical underpinnings of
that final drive throwing the ball as
much as they did anthony after the game
was asked why didn't you run the ball on
that potential go ahead drive let's hear
what lynn had to say
i was trying to move the ball down the
field you know we needed to score and uh
they did a heck of a job they locked us
up
and um i think we had eight shots i
don't think we gained one yard so you
know we gave up put ourselves in
position to win at the end we didn't
stop anybody and we didn't make any
plays on offense it's disappointing
when josh jacobs scored that touchdown
my first thought was oh crap there's too
much time on the clock and then when
daniel carlson misses the extra point my
next thought is and this is
here it goes the chargers are going to
do it and you know they did throw some
controlled passes that were aimed at
just you know moving the sticks and
getting that but it just was off like
you said he was off and he would have
had a couple of more interceptions last
night they were bailed out by penalties
there was a questionable interference
call in the first half that knocked out
a carl joseph interception there would
have been a third eric harris
interception he would have pulled off
the rod martin feat with three
interceptions if a guy wasn't lined up
in the neutral zone so philip rivers had
a bad night and it finished in a
horrible horrible way but i think
they've been thinking about moving on
from philip rivers big cat for the past
couple of years i know sims had heard
that maybe they were going to take a
shot on desean watson and they're one of
the teams that in hindsight can say why
didn't we take patrick homes or deshaun
watson in 2017. but there was some talk
that maybe they were thinking to sean
watson i remember when marcus mariota
came out there were rumors that maybe
they were going to try to get him and
unload philip rivers then i think that
this is it this is his last year with
the chargers i don't think it's his last
year in the nfl but i think he is done
with the chargers and you know what i
thought derek carr was going to be done
with the raiders after this year
derek carr
even though they could still maybe look
to upgrade at the quarterback position
and ultimately that may be the
difference between being a playoff team
and an elite team
and they're going to be seven and four
unless they get upset one of the next
two weeks against the bengals in the
jets
mike i'll go one further i think john
gruden might be coach of the year i
think he deserves coach of the year for
what this team has done their vegas win
total was six before the season they are
going to like you said who do they have
next the bengals and who else
the jets the bengals and the jets so
they will hit their vegas win total
they'll go over that
by week 12. i mean this team has been
wildly impressive i think we all thought
it was going to be another rebuilding
year where they weren't going to be able
to put together a lot of wins they go on
the road for five straight weeks because
that bears game was in london that
people got to remember to bring a team
on the road five straight weeks i
remember that vikings game uh mike when
when it felt like it could all teeter
and everything could fall apart they go
in in indianapolis they win a really
good game there they beat a bears team
that was still had a pulse in week five
in london so i think this raiders team
has been very very impressive and jon
gruden what he has done with a young
roster
a tough schedule five games on the road
keeping this all together oh and by the
way mike they're moving they're moving
and they don't know sometimes where
they're gonna play we've seen this
before i mean bill belichick has talked
about the weight of of uh what what what
caused you know the browns when they
were moving to baltimore what that what
that did to that team that year
uh jeff fisher has talked about moving
from st louis to la it is very difficult
to keep a team together when when you
know you're gonna move the team to a new
city now obviously it's not a huge move
and it's been in the works for a long
time but i still think that john gruden
has done a phenomenal job and i i count
myself as one of the people who made a
lot of jokes at his expense but he has
put this thing together and it looks
like the raiders are on the right path
and they are a legitimate wild card
contender they are a team that can sneak
into that sixth spot in the afc and i
never thought i'd be saying that after
week 10.
and if they do make it to the playoffs i
think he will get coach of the year
votes people ask me all the time if bill
belichick is the greatest coach of all
time in the history of sport period how
is he not the coach of the year every
year well the coach of the year ends up
going to the coach whose team best
exceeds the loose and general
expectations for that team going into
the season you think the raiders are
going to stink they make it to the
playoffs their coach must be coach of
the year right you've got the colts
andrew luck retires two weeks before the
start of the season they make it to the
playoffs frank reich's coach of the year
you've got a team like the packers with
matt laflore and look at what they're
doing and we didn't really expect much
we didn't know what to expect they
hadn't made the playoffs for two
straight years they end up the one seed
matt lafleur coach of the year it's all
determined by what we expected going in
and as the season started for the
raiders
we didn't expect anything i remember how
stunned i was that they beat the broncos
week one on the monday night football
night camp like ah it's just the broncos
and then they lose the next two but yeah
boom they beat the colts and then they
took care of the bears and like this
team's for real and they fought through
some adversity and and this whole idea
of not having a home and and and just
seven weeks away from oakland and it
does here's here's the thing that really
i don't know i i'm having a hard time
processing this i love the shots of john
gruden mingling with the fans after the
game and i respect the folks in oakland
for being as
as positive as they can possibly be
knowing the team is about to be ripped
out from their chests right i and and
maybe there's wisdom in making it a
three-year separation you can cycle
through all of the stages of grief
before you get to the point where the
team leaves and bringing back marshawn
lynch was genius bringing back john
gruden was genius it made those final
years a celebration more than you know
just angst and hatred and we're not
going to the games and it's just going
to be one ugly showing after another so
i like how the raiders have handled
their exit when i see shots last like
last night though i wish they weren't
leaving yeah i absolutely agree mike i
tweeted that last night it it breaks my
heart when i see this there's nothing
worse than when a
franchise is ripped out of the hands of
a very loyal passionate fan base we've
seen relocation in the nfl throughout
the years there have been times when
okay teams leaving i mean listen i i
think the charter should be in san diego
but the chargers fan base was nowhere
near what the raiders fan base is i
still think they should be in san diego
i'd like to see them go back to san
diego but this one isn't especially like
i know they've been a transient
franchise they've been in la in their
history but still
it hurts to watch
the black hole the oakland raiders fan
base get their their beloved franchise
taken away from them and i yeah they'll
still root because they're diehards and
vegas isn't that far away but it's
there's something about what oakland was
what what oakland is right now going on
the black hole it was so unique to the
nfl and it's uh something that we're
losing as fans of the nfl to see that
you know eight times a year
all right we're going to take a break
and continue this conversation about the
thursday night game it was a game that a
few weeks ago you look at it on the
schedule and think uh but it ended up
being a great game with playoff
implications
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports